[Music]
Hey
my name is Cameron Ketchum I work on the
material design components team or MDC
Android for short and I work out of the
New York City office and my name is
Gotham sachet I also work on MDC Android
and I'm based in San Francisco and we're
gonna talk a little bit about material
design components and how you can theme
your app so quickly what we're gonna
discuss a brief history of material
design what material theming is using
material design components the color
type and shape subsystems how to apply
these subsystems as well as our release
process and a little bit about
contributing so quickly just a brief
history of material design library
material design was first announced in
2014 and there wasn't a design library
then at i/o in 2015 a year later Google
finally announced the design support
library which helped bring a lot of code
for material design for certain
components including a navigation drawer
floating action buttons snack bar etc
but there still wasn't that much and at
i/o this year we announced material
theming with the explicit goal to have a
larger engineering team behind it so
we're working on implementing a lot of
the components based on the material
design spec and so material theming what
was the original problem with material
design well it was a great initial
version of a design system it worked
well in a lot of cases but it fell short
what the expression of brand so here's
an example of an email app and it looks
kind of like every other app that used
material design and it's kind of hard to
tell that it's even an email app in my
opinion here's an example of the kinds
of things that you can do with material
theming to make your app stand out and
we're gonna get into those details in a
bit so quickly how does theming work
basically material theming is a system
that we've designed to help you create a
unique design for your app you just need
to decide on a few things such as fonts
colors shapes etc and this is a material
design sketch plug-in that can be used
with which should help you create design
ideas that you can use to build your app
take a look at material dot IO for more
info about that tool here's a few
material studies that we've done which
just show examples of material theming
and you can see that they all look quite
different and there's also a lot more of
these on material I oh cool
so now let's get talking about how to
actually get started using the material
components library so imagine this
scenario that will come back to a couple
times throughout this talk you got this
fairly plain app that you built from
just straight app compat and your
teammate asks you to redesign this using
the material design spec so how do you
go about doing this so you may be
familiar with the support library design
package this b28 version that you can
use to get our library and you can use
this however this is no longer being
updated so you should try and use the
konbu build Android material library as
well as Android X one thing to note you
can't use the Kannada Android support
and conduct google android packages
together so if you want to switch over
to Android X there's a nice refactor
tool on the developer Android side
that'll help you refactor your app and
the next thing you'll need to do is use
our material themes so we provide this
set of themes that corresponds to the
existing app compat themes and these
themes provide you with a range of
attributes that help you do some of the
shape color type theming that we're
gonna be talking about as well as a set
of default styles that you can use
across all of our components so for
example if your theme extends from app
compat lite
all you need to do is switch over to
theme that material components salt
light and you should have all of our
attributes as well as all of our
component styles so as I mentioned
there's a lot of new attributes that
were going to be introducing and if you
try to use our components without these
attributes defined
you're gonna get a themed enforcement
error at one time pretty much the Styles
look for these attributes in your theme
and if they don't exist it's going to
crash your runtime so the solution to
this is of course use our theme and
we'll give you all the attributes if
you're not quite ready to switch over to
our full theme quite yet you just want
to get the attributes and none of the
Styles you can use what are called the
bridge themes and what these bridge
themes do is they provide you all the
attributes you need to do styling but
they don't give you any of the default
styles so you can opt into using our
component styles one by one as you're
ready to switch over so for example if
you're extending from a bridge theme and
you want to opt-in to use our bottom app
bar style you would define the default
bottom app bar style in your theme and
then all of your bottom app bars would
get the material component style so now
we're just going to talk a little bit
about some new components with material
theming we introduced a few new things
such as the bottom app bar and bottom
app bar displays navigation and key
actions at the bottom of mobile screens
which is great for people or just
one-handed using their thumb to interact
with the device it's pretty simple it
uses a coordinator layout to coordinate
the motion between a bottom app bar and
a floating action button and so here we
just have simple XML for the bottom app
bar a few of the things that you can do
is set the vertical offset of the fab
you can also set the fab cradle margin
which is the distance between the fab
and the bottom app bar as well as the
rounded corner radius which is where the
corner where the bottom app bar meets
the fab you can have the bottom app bar
hide on scroll and you can also set this
alignment mode it will automatically
animate the fab for you and it's useful
if you're navigating between different
fragments or views and want to give a
visual distinction between different
screens if you're already using a
toolbar it's super easy to start using
the bottom app bar if you're setting the
support action bar for the toolbar just
set it for the bottom app bar instead
and everything else works the same way
but you can also use an on menu item
click listener
on the bottom app bar we also have
what's a revamped version of the button
that we're calling material button it's
been revamped to make styling much
simpler so if you just put this material
button component in your XML you'll get
a styled button however if you're using
our full theme you can actually just use
a button tag in your XML and we do
what's called custom view inflation
where this tag will automatically
inflate into a material button tag and
then of course you can set the disabled
State on this button and all the states
will transfer over colors will transfer
over
you can set an icon on this button just
by setting the icon attribute as well as
this icon style and this style is
optional but what it'll do is it'll
adjust the padding slightly to achieve a
more even visual balance on the button
when the icon is present you can change
the icon size just using the attribute
you can set the outline button style
which is one of the default styles that
we provide for this button to get this
hairline outline button you can set the
background tint of the button by setting
the background to an attribute and you
can provide a color state list here so
in this case it's purple when the button
is enabled and grey one is disabled you
can set some other attributes such as
stroke width stroke color corner radius
on this button to get some styling you
can also create just an icon only button
in this case we're setting the icon as
well as setting the icon padding to zero
so that the icon is centered in the
button and we are also setting the
content description on this button so
since there's no text for accessibility
reasons you should set a content
description so that people will know
what the bun is about you can also set
the ripple color on the button so for
example if you just set a purple ripple
on here it'll be applied to the button
you can set either a color state list or
just a hex value here and as you can see
it's like a purple ripple on the button
well that's because there's am alpha
already inherent in the ripple so it's a
purple ripple on top of a green button
and these are some of the examples of
the other components that we provide in
this library we have several different
styles of chips
we have text fields with filled and
outline styles passwords show and hide
functionality and a character counter
and then we have some highly
customizable tab layouts as well okay
and now a little bit about deeming MDC
relies heavily on the built in theming
event of Android so here's just a quick
refresher of how themes and styles work
anything applied directly to a view and
XML is used first so changing an
attribute here will only change this
single view you can also update a the
style so if you set an attribute in a
style changing this here will affect any
any views that are using this style if
it's not defined in a style or there's
no style set it'll it'll go back to the
default style so here if you want to
change the way a whole group of
components look you can set the default
style and then finally if that tribute
isn't defined anywhere else
it'll look in the theme and the way
material theming works normally is
there's a set of top-level attributes
that you should override in your theme
for typography colors shapes etc and
also the default styles for all of the
components but if you need more
fine-grained control you can hook in and
any of these layers and change like just
the color of a single view or just the
color of like all of a certain component
so here's an example from our library of
the chip style it defines a few values
which reference the match buttes and the
power of this design comes from the fact
that other styles in our library can
reference these same attributes so
here's an example of a button and both
of these have the same shape appearance
which is the small component shape
appearance that means that if we want to
update the look and feel of our app for
these shape for these small components
all we have to do is update this
attribute in one place in our theme and
we'll show you an example of how to do
that in a little bit
what are the effects of each of these
theme attributes unfortunately it's not
totally straightforward we try to apply
theme attributes in a way that will make
sense but it's definitely possible for
you to pick values for like different
colors that may not look great together
you should probably check out material
do for each component to see how it'll
react but another simple possible
another simple solution that you could
do potentially is to make like a debug
theme which just says sets wacky values
to different attributes and then see how
things look but for instance here's the
bottom map bar a page on the material I
of site and you can see there that the
the container itself is like a surface
and the icons or the on surface and
we'll talk about which attributes you
can modify as well as things to look out
for in the next section
so theming subsystems we currently have
three theming subsystems type color and
shape and these are the knobs that you
as a developer should tweak in order to
theme your app hopefully most of you are
familiar with text appearances but we've
incorporated material theming which uses
theme attributes to reference these text
appearances so here's an example of a
tool bar which uses the headlines
headlines six attribute rather than
style directly and here's some copy that
uses the body 1 attribute these are the
type attributes that we've defined so if
you override any of these in your theme
you can set the style and look of your
app color is another one and you're
probably familiar with the app compat
color primary and color accent from
material theming we have a wider range
of colors so that you have more control
over the color of different parts of
your app these are the semantic names of
the expanded pallet of colors that work
with color of theming on the top here we
have primary primary variants secondary
secondary very
those are all the brand colors those are
the things that you should generally
seem to be the style of your app there's
also a background surface and error
colors you can style those but you don't
necessarily have to and then the on
primary on secondary those on variant of
colors those need to be accessible when
they're drawn on top of the other colors
so for instance on primary that will be
drawn on top of the primary color so if
you have text that's shown on top of the
primary background it should be the on
primary color these are the color
attributes that we've defined you can
see that there's a lot of new ones we
tried to reuse some that came from app
compat and we also have the Android
color background that we use as just
which is just the regular Android
version of that attribute shape is
another subsystem that you can theme and
it all happens with material shape
drawable so we're adding material shape
drawable as the background for shape the
mobile components such as buttons cards
fab bottom app bar bottom sheet chips
etc and the way it works is with edge
and corner treatments so we have edge
and corner treatments defined for
rounded and cut corner which is pretty
much every button or interactable
component that you're gonna find but you
can always create your own as well so
here's an example of Kotlin code which
defines a rounded corner treatment and
sets that to the material shape drawable
to apply just rounded corners to
everything and here is the xml version
as well so if you want to do it in xml
we have a new attribute called shape
appearance and it's similar to the text
appearance of attributes here are the
corner family and the corner size and
this sets it to be a rounded corner with
24 DP radius and you can override
individual corners so here we're just
overriding the top-left corner to be cut
in the bottom right corner to have a
corner size of zero and you can do the
same thing in XML and one thing to
notice is that we're using a shape
appearance overlay here which is
basically the same thing except for we
only define the attributes that we want
to override so it's similar to a theme
overlay and that the material button on
its own already has a shape appearance
by default and here we're just setting
the top left corner to be cut and the
bottom right corner to be 0dp everything
else will be inherited from the style of
the material button one key idea of
material theming is to add consistency
to your app so we've defined these shape
mappings to help these are different
groups of components that can help give
your app a more consistent looking feel
by connecting surfaces through shape so
there's small medium and large
components and these are the attributes
that you can set in your theme so if you
want to restyle all the small components
to have a cut right corner or something
you can do that here's an example where
just like I said we're overriding the
small component style so we redefine the
small appearance the small component
shape appearance and the theme to our
style and here we're setting the top
right corner to be cut and we're also
setting the parent here so that will
inherit all of the other the rounded
corners for the other parts shadow is
something that we want to mention as
well
native elevation is supported for convex
shapes on lollipop for API 21 and up but
we're back porting shadows to API 15 for
both concave and convex shape shapes for
common cases such as rounded or cut
corners as well as for the bottom app
bar because this has the cut out inside
of it it won't get in native shadow so
we fake the shadow with a gradient so
now that we've heard a bit about our
gaming subsystems let's look at how to
actually apply those to your out
so coming back to the scenario again say
you have this app compat app that you
want to apply some of these theming
subsystems to so we're gonna be building
something that looks a little like this
and obviously when you build your own
apps it'll look much more beautiful and
cohesive than this but we're tweaking as
many knobs as we can to show you some of
the functionality what we built Oh
so first thing you'd have to do is if
you're using an app compat light no
action bar theme you can switch over its
a material components theme and in this
case you'll notice we're using the
bridge theme because we want to opt into
using those components one by one but
generally recommend that you switch to
the full theme the regular theme and see
how it looks first before trying out the
bridge theme um so let's say first thing
you do is you set these theme color
attributes so some of the existing ones
that you already know or a color primary
in color secondary those still exist and
then some of the new theme color
attributes such as color on primary on
secondary color surface and color on
surface are also set you'll see this
color secondary doesn't really show up
anywhere in your app yet but it will
next thing we want to do is get material
button so before we have those app
compat buttons and then if you set the
material button style in your theme all
of your buttons should turn into
material buttons when you change the XML
tag as I mentioned before if you're
using our full theme this inflation
happens automatically so you don't
actually have to change this XML at all
we have a bunch of other default styles
that we've laid out here all our
components have a default style that you
can set in the theme it's generally just
component name plus style for example if
you want to set the card style you would
set material card view style in your
theme and then we're going to be
applying so you should also change the
card view to material card view in this
case in your XML and then we're going to
be applying some attributes to these
cards so for instance you can set card
elevation stroke color and stroke width
and that'll show up across all of your
cards because it's setting the default
style and also all the cards look at
this default style and then say you
wanted to change the base style of all
the buttons you would define your own
button style and set the parents of it
to outline button which is one of our
default cells and then all of your
buttons change into outline buttons
we can now apply some shape theming to
all of your buttons so we're gonna
define the shape appearance shaped
button style and in that button style
we're gonna set the right corners to be
cut and the left corner speed round 'add
and we're gonna set the corner size and
now you have this arrow shaped button
you can also do the Stewart using a
shape appearance overlay since buttons
have a rounded corner by default you
don't really have to set the rounded
corner for the left side so if you use
the shape appearance overlay you can
just set what you're changing and it'll
take effect as normal and then say we
wanted to have some icon buttons you
would define this icon button style set
the padding's and min widths as you want
and then apply this to yearbut to your
button directly in the xml as well as
setting that icon and content
description and then you have this share
icon button instead of that share text
button you can also switch over to the
bottom app bar so for this you'd have to
set the bottom app bar style in your
theme and then remove the top app bar
from your XML layout and add this bottom
app bar here you can also add a floating
action button cradled into the spot in
that bar by adding the floating action
button to your layout and then setting
the layout anchor attribute to point to
the ID at the bottom app bar you'll
notice that this fab has that teal color
from app compat and that's because we
haven't set the default floating action
button style yet so once you set that
you'll see that it's now using color
secondary and color on secondary and it
has that ripple effect as well then we
can do some text styling for the content
of our cards say you want all of your
all of your text to be color on surface
rather than whatever it was previously
we're gonna be using what's called a
material theme overlay which I'll talk
about in just a second but material
theme overlaid pretty much sets the
theme for all the contents of that
component so in this case we're setting
the text color primary and tertiary to
set the text color of our of our notes
here and so material theme overlay you
might have heard of Android theme it's
the way you can style a sub section of
your
hierarchy and one common usage of this
is style say a dark-colored toolbar in
your app the shortcoming of Android
theme is that it doesn't work in default
styles so for instance if you wanted to
style all of your cards you can't really
set Android theme so material theme
overlays an attribute that we've defined
that's supported by our components and
it does work in default styles so you
can set this in your default styles for
your components and have a theme the sub
views of your components
lastly we'll do some text appearance
theming so previously the title was had
this hard-coded text appear in style now
we're gonna be switching over to our new
text appearance attributes and similarly
for the for the text for the note body
as well and then we can apply some
styling to this so for example if you
change headline six to be Comic Sans for
instance you can change all the
components that use headline six in your
app it should now look like this so why
go through the trouble of doing this
like why go through the trouble of like
using top-level attributes throughout
your Styles like what's what's the
reason and generally we do this because
we want to be able to tell your entire
app using only these top-level
attributes so say for instance your
teammate came up to you and said hey our
brand colors are changing now so
actually we want we want this maroon
color and so these blues that we had all
you have to do is switch some of these
top-level color attributes and your
whole app is redeemed similarly if you
want a dark theme or a fake dark theme
of sorts all you have to do is change a
couple of these other color attributes
and the component should all respond
appropriately to that and you have a
different looking out now we're going to
talk a little bit about custom
components and how you can use styles
and some of your components that you've
created there's really nothing magical
about the way our components use theming
it's all just basic Android theming so
you can use it in your components as
well you just have to create a default
style past that default style attribute
into your constructor and use obtained
styled attributes so
let's go through that here we have a
definition of a theme and some
attributes here we're creating a default
style attribute and setting it in our
theme so we have this must my custom
view style and we're setting it to this
widget that my custom view style that
we've defined somewhere in our theme so
this will mean that any components that
use this my custom view or any of these
my custom views will use this style by
default you also can create a style Obul
which holds a few different attributes
and then you just need to use these in
the Constructors so here's an example of
a constructor for a view here we pass in
the default style which we created
previously and we pass this in here so
that it can pick up that default style
if nothing else is set and then we're
using obtain styled attributes and we
pass in the style that we just created
as well as the default style attribute
that was passed into the constructor and
finally a fallback style that can be
used as a last resort for finding
attributes and then just read those in
and that's basically how our components
work so you can definitely do it
yourself as well and also extend the
systems for your use cases right like if
you have the need for more attributes in
some case you can definitely add those
in it might be a little bit more work on
your part because you'll have to update
styles for all of the components that
are using to reference those attributes
since our components that we're writing
aren't going to be referencing them but
if you need it you can definitely do
that
here too here's an example it's just
like an attribute just create it and
define it in your style and then
reference it or to find it in your theme
and then reference it in styles or
elsewhere and now a little bit about our
process we've had a few releases
the 1.0 went out and was cut on July
20th and it's been a little while but
now with the Android X jetpack refactor
finished we can release more frequently
because we're not tied to the sport
library so we're trying to ramp up our
releases and we finally cut 1 point 1
alpha 1 October 31st and we're
definitely trying to do this more
frequently around once a month at least
the 1.1 alpha had the type theming color
theming and dark theming that we've
talked about in this plus lots of bug
fixes and performance improvements in
the upcoming releases we're gonna have a
shape theming which I talked about in
1.1 alpha the shape theming subsystem
exists but none of the components are
actually responding to those themed
attributes yet but with the next release
it should we also updated some styling
for dialogues bottom sheet menus those
sorts of things are all coming and as
far as contributing and filing issues
github is where our code is so if you're
interested in taking a look just go and
get hub you can take a look at all of
our code it's open source and also check
you can check github for instructions on
how to submit bug reports we're trying
to figure out what works best right now
we're taking bug reports at this issue
tracker dot Google recognizer component
but we're looking at different ways to
make it more obvious what we're working
on and trying to integrate more with the
community and here's a few more
resources material do site is great
especially the Android section
definitely check us out on discord if
you're interested in chatting with us or
are interested in helping us have a PR
an idea for anything just like come and
chat with us we have a tag on Stack
Overflow so if you have questions about
implementation you can ask something
there we're watching that and we'll
respond and then we have a few code labs
you can find the link to those code labs
on this github page and that's pretty
much it
thanks for coming thank you
[Applause]
[Music]